my story is on a new book by Fox News
anchor Chris Wallace on the final months
before the u.s. dropped the atomic bomb
it's called countdown 1945 the
extraordinary story of the atomic bomb
and the 116 days that changed the world
it starts with Harry Truman becoming
president and finding out the US was
secretly developing a new weapon the
book is published by avid reader press
an imprint of Simon & Schuster which is
a division of Viacom CBS Chris Wallace
joins us now Chris good morning I want
to get to your book in a sec but I want
to start with welcome thanks for being
here I want to start with some of the
events that occurred over the weekend we
we had we had colon Powell announcing
that he was gonna vote for Joe Biden we
have of course last week general mattis
criticism criticism the president he
served you saw Mitt Romney marching in a
protest and saying the word black lives
matter and then George Will came out in
a column basically saying the whole
Republican Party needs to be rebooted
now some of these people obviously have
been critical of the president in the
past but but do you think there's there
is something happening here well there
certainly happened something happening
in the top levels the establishment of
the Republican Party you do see some
people breaking with an incumbent
president think about that this isn't
Donald Trump who was just a candidate
four years ago he's the Republican
president so that's quite impressive on
the other hand if you do look at the
polls the president still has tremendous
support from the Republican base eighty
ninety percent of Republicans support
him so so I don't think there is a real
stampede away from the president and the
party there certainly is a stampede or
at least a bit a bit of a run away at
the top levels but you know I think
Donald Trump would say I never had those
people with me anyway and I suspect
he'll use it to say to his base you know
I'm with you guys I'm not with the elite
of the Republican Party Chris we've all
been watching the protests they continue
they were significant this weekend and
watch
and again do you think it's different
this time well that's you know the big
question I keep asking myself because
you know we're all veterans you and Gale
and Tony and me and we've seen this
story before whether it was Rodney King
or Eric garner Michael Brown in Ferguson
where you know there's a case of alleged
or in most cases confirmed undo police
force and protests some of them turning
into riots and calls for reform and
frankly nothing much happens and that's
the big question here and I don't have
been answered to it will things happen
the houses House Democrats are going to
propose a bill today that includes
things like more transparency some kind
of register for police who have
misconduct claims against them maybe
take away some of their qualified
immunity but will that get through
Congress and the Republican Senate I'm
not sure about that and I'm not sure how
much of a difference it will make so
we'll have to wait and see but being a
little bit of a skeptic I think it's
more likely that that we're gonna see
this story tragically again sometime in
a couple of years and say now we need to
make some changes one of the things I
was struck in in reading your book Chris
countdown 1945 and it reads like a
thriller by the way it really does cuz
you have you have the new president
Harry Truman coming into office and not
even realizing that an atomic bomb was
under development and suddenly facing
whether he should use it or not and and
one of the things that struck me is
there's an extraordinary amount of unity
in the government as they consider this
decision isn't there absolutely I mean
you know there as you're right
researching and then writing a book of
history you're always comparing that to
current times and one of the things that
really struck me was the extraordinary
unity we were in the middle of World War
two but whether it was the top military
the top scientists the top politicians
or just folks on the home front they
were all pulling together and one of the
astonishing facts is that for three
years a Manhattan Project was under way
a hundred and twenty five thousand
people at Oak Ridge Tennessee and out at
los alamos in New Mexico Hanford
Washington Wendover Utah and not a
single bit of the of the project broke
now obviously they didn't have the
internet or social media things that we
have today but it's they it was a secret
in the state a secret because everybody
was on the same team boy could we use
that now yeah and and and Chris Truman
was very methodical you point out about
his decision-making
he took counsel from everyone including
generals who disagreed correct yeah this
is one of the things that I really
appreciated about Truman he first of all
it was meticulous the choice was do we
invade Japan or do we use the atom bomb
maybe the biggest decision any president
had to make and he sought out advice
from everybody he has lunch just a few
days before the bomb has dropped with
Dwight Eisenhower the supreme Allied
commander Eisenhower says the Japanese
were already gonna surrender we
shouldn't be the first country to
unleash the bomb now Truman didn't
follow his advice but he didn't hate it
he didn't yell at him or throw him out
of the room he welcomed it he wanted the
best straightest advice from everybody
around to me but he said when I make the
decision you're back mate right Chris
Wallace it's a fascinating read thank
you so much for being with us this
morning countdown 1945 is on sale
tomorrow